Where did Russia come from?
Why is it so big, and what are the differences between it and its neighbors?
The answers lie in an epic story of seafaring warriors,...
...nomadic invaders, and the rise and fall of a medieval state known as Kievan Rus.
For several generations, the Kievan Rus flourished...
...from its rich resources and trade.
It's noblemen and noblewomen married prominent European rulers,...
...while residents of some cities enjoyed great culture, literacy...
...and even democratic freedoms uncommon for the time.
Until 1237, when 35,000 mounted archers led by Batu Khan...
...swept through those cities, sacking Kiev...
...before continuing on to Hungary and Poland.
The age of Kievan Rus had come to an end,...
...its people now divided.
In the east, which remained under Mongol rule,...
...a remote trading post known as Moscow...
...would grow to challenge the power of the khans,...
...conquering parts of their fragmenting empire,...
...and in many ways, succeeding it.
As it absorbed other eastern Rus territories,...
...it reclaimed the old name in its Greek form, "Russia."
The former lands of Kievan Rus,...
...populated by Slavs, ruled by Vikings, taught by Greeks, and split by Mongols...
...would develop differences in society, culture and language...
...that remain to the present day.